If your intuition tells you that
the incremental approach of
the Ford-Fulkerson method produces
a maximum flow, that's a good thing.
Your intuition is correct.
But it's important that it be
correct for the right reasons.
Not all incremental approaches work.
Often in optimization, we get stuck
in local minima or local maxima.
We need to argue either that
we never make a mistake,
the analysis of greedy algorithms
typically have this feel.
Or we need to be able to argue
that the rules for incrementing
allows us to undo any mistakes
that we have made along the way.
The latter will be the case for
maximum flow.
The argument we'll make is complex,
and will require us to introduce a new
notion of a minimum
cutograph along the way.
But in the end it's rewarding, and
provides an example of how to
find elegance in analysis.
To show that Ford-Fulkerson returns
a maximum flow, we're going to introduce
the concept of a cut, and then relate
the capacity of a cut to a flow.
Here's a picture of our understanding so
far.
We know that the network will have some
possible non-negative flow values, but
it's not exactly clear how
high this range goes, or
where the results of
Ford-Fulkerson fit in.
One observation is that the flow
value can't exceed the capacity of
edges coming out of the source.
Remember that the flow is defined to be
the sum of the flows over these edges.
Separating S from T in this way
constitutes a cut in the graph which,
as we'll see, is an upper bound
on the value of any flow.
It's possible that there will
be smaller cuts as well,
which will shrink the range of
possible flow values for us.
Even better, however, we'll see that
the flow produced by Ford- Fulkerson
has the same value as the cut.
And since this cut serves as an upper
bound on all possible flows,
this flow must be a maximum.
That's where this argument will end up.